there we go hi I'm Matthew Steiner matt
is a certified senior crime scene
analyst he's explained crime scene
forensics in technique critique so
that's a really interesting yet very a
legal way to get DNA from somebody today
I'm going to show you how to analyze
various blood stain patterns in this
episode we'll learn the techniques
forensics experts use to investigate
blood stain patterns ranging from easy
to difficult so normally when we go to a
crime scene it's not set up like this
unless we have some sort of Dexter X
crime scene where the killer really
planned it out today we're doing on set
for safety purposes for us at crime
scenes when we investigate them safety
is number one we want to protect
ourselves I think we various blood-borne
pathogens that we're dealing with and
the secondly we don't want to
contaminate the crime scene so we don't
want the hairs the fibers on ourselves
the DNA the shedding off us falling onto
our evidence at a crime scene we'd wear
multiple layers of gloves if we're gonna
be handling evidence and then we'd want
to wear eye protection if there's like a
splash hazard with blood that hasn't
been dried so our Tyvek suit covers most
of our body including our feet because
we want to be introducing our shoe wear
impressions into a crime scene or
destroying evidence that's there so
normally I'd be wearing a mask but I
don't think it's really good look for
talking on camera next we're going to
talk about the three main categories of
bloodstains that we can encounter at a
crime scene
today we're going to be using
defibrillated sheep's blood we have
taken the fibrin out of this blood
fibrin is a protein that's in our plasma
that causes our blood to clot so if we
use regular whole blood that had the
fibrin in it we'd have a clotted mess
inside this bottle
let's same pattern analysts correlate
the appearance of these blood stain
patterns at a crime scene to a mechanism
by which they were created it isn't a
crystal ball it isn't like the way TV
presents it where a crime scene
investigator walks into a scene and
could tell you every single action that
happened inside that crime scene from
beginning to end analysts can correlate
the static bloodstains at a crime scene
with dynamic forces that create them so
we look at is specific stain patterns
and we could figure out how they
possibly were created and then with that
we could show a small window of time not
the whole crime but that this type of
force could have created this sort of
pattern so passive patterns are patterns
that are created with database and
outside external force other than
gravity or contact so we're gonna first
start off with dropping blood at 90
degrees to see what we get so I'm going
to take pipette and a small amount of
blood and hold it directly above and
drop it
so when our spear of blood strikes a
surface at 90 degrees we have a very
even round circle at a crime scene but
also it affects the way our blood stain
looks is the surface itself we have
Plexiglas and we noticed that the edge
characteristics of our blood stain are
very even now that we observed the way
that blood acts on a smooth surface
let's try tile which has a little bit of
texture to it one drop of blood straight
down onto a different surface now you
could see a little bit of scalloping
around the edges there that's because of
the surface texture so the scalloping is
just of different ways that we describe
the edge characteristics of bloodstains
so it could be smooth uniform
it could be scalloped or it could be
spiny so now we change our surface to a
rougher surface wood so we see a vast
difference from where we started we have
smooth edge characteristics now we have
the spiny err pattern because that blood
drop is being disrupted by the surface
itself and we can also see we have some
satellite stains satellite stains are
stains that come off of
aren't stained so this main stain here
is my parents stain in this case because
the disruption they are being forced out
from the center of it we also see
satellite spatter when blood is being
dripped into blood typically at a crime
scene especially with stabbings we want
to look for these drip patterns it could
be that the suspect accidentally cuts
themselves and they're moving around a
crime scene and fleeing the crime scene
and they could leave blood trails that
we could follow next we're gonna be
looking at contact transfer stands a
transfer pattern is a passive pattern
where we have a bloody surface coming in
contact with another surface and then
sometimes we could actually figure out
what made that transfer whether it was a
hand or a weapon or someone's clothing I
mean that's the best type of evidence
that we could have at a crime scene so
we have the victim's blood and we have
the suspects impression there's very few
explanations of how that happens so
we're gonna start off with a shoe wear
impression in blood so this could be our
victim walking through blood creating
patterns in our crime scene or this
could be the suspects shoe wear
impression we're gonna coat the bottom
of the shoe and we're gonna transfer the
pattern at the bottom of the shoe to our
clean surface now I have my shoe wear
that's completely coated in blood and
then inside that crime scene we have a
transfer of that pattern and we'll
notice is that that pattern gets lighter
and lighter as we move a lot what we
don't see what our naked eye we could
find later on with chemicals like
luminol a blue star so we could see a
continuation of that pattern as someone
walks away from a crime scene
sometimes we see transfer patterns in
textiles so next we're gonna take some
blood saturate a portion of our jeans
with it and we're gonna transfer that
onto our surface so sometimes in real
crime scenes these get misinterpreted as
the lines of minutiae and your finger
prints or palm print we would see is
that unlike fingerprints are just
straight lines either way we would
document this and collect it and sensor
lab and then under magnification analyze
it so next we're gonna discuss how
movement could affect these transfers
stain patterns so I'm gonna take some
blood and put it onto my hand and then
move that across the surface so if I
test a surface and then move my hand we
see what's called feathering the
effective movement on blood just like if
I took a paint brush and moved it across
a wall and in the beginning would be
darker but eventually it would get
lighter
so this feathering effect helps
interpret movement at a crime scene this
could be found at a crime scene in many
different ways one could be our suspect
has blood on their hands and they move
it across a clean surface and another
very common way that we see these
patterns at a crime scene or what's
called drag marks we have a victim
that's bleeding and either they're
moving through the scene or someone's
dragging them to the scene and we'd see
the same effect that feathering going
towards the body next we're gonna cover
a flow patterns and that is a volume of
blood being affected by gravity so we
can see here is that gravity is pulling
upon that blood and pulling it down on
our surface at crime scenes this may be
very valuable evidence when we observe
our victim's injuries person had an
injury to their shoulder if they're
standing or if their body is erect that
flow pattern should go straight down
their arm but if they've been moved or
this movement or that injury was caused
when they're laying down we'd see a
different flow pattern so next we're
gonna discuss saturation and pooling
patterns that we have at a crime scene
saturation and pooling patterns could
tell us that someone is bleeding and a
certain part in a crime scene for a
period of time you know sometimes when
we see bubbles at a scene that could
mean that we have a expert a pattern or
a pattern that's coming from airway but
let's pop those because we don't but
what this could tell me is that we had
accumulation of blood there and that
there's been no movement because if this
happened and then we moved the shirt we
would see that the blood would move in
that direction typically we'll see this
on mattresses or beds or bedding and it
would absorb a little more so now we're
going to have an accumulation of blood
on a non-porous surface and we'll see
pooling so pooling and saturation it's
the same mechanism or looking at just
the accumulation of blood but what
pooling the blood is not being absorbed
into the surface for pools of blood what
we'll see with actual whole blood that
has fibrin in it they will dry a lot
slower than it would in something that's
absorbent but also we're going to see
over a period of time is clotting inside
that pool and then sometimes we'll see
effect what's called serum separation so
the edges of this will be clear where we
see the plasma of the blood as it
separates so now we're moving on to the
spatter category of blood same pattern
Alice
with this category of bloodstains we're
looking at some sort of external force
on an open source of blood so I'm gonna
do is gonna put a small amount of blood
on there wood here I'm gonna strike it
with the hammer and what we we should
see is an impact spatter on the
Plexiglas in front of us put on my
goggles I'm gonna put my hood up a small
amount of blood here all right you ready
there we go so as you can see not only
do we have impact spatter on the
Plexiglas in front of us we also have it
on our suspect there okay so we applied
force to an open source of blood and we
have a resulting impact stain our stain
pattern what we will notice is directly
opposite where the force was applied we
have our blood striking that surface at
90 degrees so these things that we have
right here near the bottom are circular
but the further we move away from that
source these bloodstains are now hitting
this surface at an angle so our stains
are more elliptical bludgeoning would be
the most common way that we get these
stains but it could be that we have the
force of a bullet passing through
somebody so we have a phenomenon called
forward spatter and back spatter so if
someone is shot and the bullet passes
through say their shoulder we have blood
going in the direction of the force or
with the bullet out of the exit but we
also have blood going the opposition of
the force and that's what we call back
spatter first up we started by creating
different patterns so we could analyze
next step we're gonna look at something
a little more difficult
[Music]
next we do is calculate the area of
convergence that's a two-dimensional
area on our surface if we draw a line
through the long axis of several stains
where all these lines will meet they
should converge in an area somewhere in
a center here what I want to do is pick
several stains that are elliptical from
different sides of the pattern we're
looking at this to solve where this
blood came from I'm gonna start with
this stain here and I'm going to line up
so that I'm drawing a line through the
long axis of my stain so this is where
the tail is gonna help me out to figure
out the directionality but also to line
up my ruler and then sometimes what
we'll do is just kind of show for a jury
an arrow the direction that stain is
going so then I'll move around the
pattern from different sides of it and
draw through different stains so this
isn't done at every crime scene but when
we have a pattern like this we have
elliptical stains along the outside we
have some circular stance towards the
inside this is the perfect opportunity
for us to do some analysis I could keep
going and draw more lines through more
stains and it should all be coming back
to the same general direction so if this
was on the wall and this is very low you
know this could be very powerful
evidence to show that you know that that
was low to the ground where this impact
happened since we identified different
stains that are striking our surface at
different angles we're gonna figure out
the angle of impact that these stains
hit our surface we do that by measuring
the length of the stain we divide it
into the width of the stain and the
arcsine of that number will give us our
angle of impact so we're measuring
stains we always want to use millimeters
allows us for smaller measurements so
what we could also use is a digital
caliper and that will give us precise
submillimetre measurements so I want to
measure the length of the stain long
axis of the stain so this is 3.1
millimeters and then I'd measure the
width of it so I'm measuring the widest
part of the same that's one point seven
millimeters we're gonna divide three
point one into 1.7 so if we do the
arcsine of that number that will give us
the angle of impact which
thirty three point two five if you had a
regular ruler you would just have to
round up to the closest millimeter so in
this case this stain is four millimeters
and then we measure the width of it two
millimeters so we would divide 4 into 2
which gives us point five and the
arcsine of 0.5 is thirty degrees and if
we can see this basically at the same
distance from our Center but just on the
other side if we look at this two
dimensionally we know that these lines
of our area of Bridgett's meet here but
if I want to think about it three
dimensionally that my blood is coming
from somewhere above it here so the next
step will be is that we're gonna
calculate the area of origin if it's
coming in at a right angle here I have a
triangle so this would be my adjacent
side of the triangle I know that it's 90
degrees from here so that's my right
triangle and then this side that the
path takes is the hypotenuse of the
triangle and so if I know the distance
from my stain to my area of convergence
and I want to figure out how far away my
area of origin is here in space if I do
the tangent of that I could figure out
the side like sohcahtoa
when we analyze bloodstains in a field I
always feels better to do all these
methods we should coming up with similar
results but if you messed up somewhere
you know one of those is going to be
correct next up we're gonna try
something a little more difficult
interpreting relationships there's an
adage that forensic science is the art
of observation governed by science so we
have observed our stain patterns at our
crime scene and we're going to interpret
how these possibly were created so if I
go to a crime scene and I see that
there's some clothing there eventually
I'm going to recover this but after I
recover it and I see that there's
passive stains underneath it I know that
this came after this that this wasn't in
place that this was placed afterwards
and if I don't see a transfer a blood on
here it could be that this was already
dry by the time this clothing went on
top of it so now we're looking at a
passive drug pattern this could be the
victim's blood this could be the
suspects blood we won't know until we
sample it and send it off for analysis
what we can interpret from this could be
movement so if this trail of blood is
leading away from the scene we would see
those tails going in a direction of
travel now we're looking at a white
pattern we have a pre-existing stain
that something came in contact and move
through it so we could see from our
discussion earlier feathering that the
directionality is coming towards me
something is passively dripping blood
that could be a weapon
that could be a victim that could be our
suspect and then something later on
comes through it that could be someone
trying to clean up the stain this could
also be that maybe someone was dragged
through this or there was some sort of
movement through that stain so that was
a white pattern now we have a swipe
pattern blood is on something here and
we could see it again that same
feathering going in a direction of
travel we have a transfer pattern with
movement which is a swipe pattern
there's blood on something and then
we're just moving that in a direction
usually when it's a white pattern we
could see those original stains so the
drawing and that someone tries to wipe
them off with a cloth now we're looking
at a cast-off pattern so this is a
subcategory of spatter that's a
projection mechanism
so blood is on an object and we're
moving that object in space that could
be someone's hand that could be a pipe
that could be a bat that could be a
knife and as that object moves blood
will be flung off it and we have these
very distinct linear patterns or
curvilinear patterns at a crime scene if
we see these cast-off patterns they can
go up the walls they can go across the
floor and even onto the ceiling so we're
looking at a spatter pattern but we have
a normally continuous drops of blood
that are being interrupted or blocked by
something and that gives us a pattern
what's called the void sometimes we have
crime scenes where there's something
important that would be in that pool or
in that pattern or that spatter pattern
and it's been removed so it could be
someone's bag or a cell phone their
wallet
I had a crime scene where if someone was
bludgeoned and adjacent to his head was
the complete absence of blood spatter
looking to the left of him there was a
spatter pattern it didn't line up what
we determined was that the curtains
inside of the hotel room were open at
the time of the crime and then closed
later on we've gone over how these
patterns are created are different
categories of patterns and what we can
interpret from these patterns at a crime
scene this is not a simple process this
stuff takes time training and experience
and beyond that there's no absolutes
with any of this there's no one specific
answer then it's only that one answer I
hope you guys learned a lot
[Applause]